This video was sponsored by the purge on
USA network.
What's up wise crack jared here.
As you know,
we're pretty big fans of the purge,
so we were stoked when USA came to us
and gave us a sneak peek of the first
two episodes of the new purge TV series,
a 10 episode television event,
Tuesdays on USA network.
We've already discussed the
socioeconomic themes prevalent in the
purge films,
but the show has already shown some
promise in extending these themes in
some interesting ways.
So for those of you excited about the
show,
we're going to go through a couple of
key philosophical and sociological
concepts to frame the way you watch it.
So without further ado,
welcome to this wise crack quick take on
what you need to know before you watch
the purge on USA.
As we've discussed in our philosophy of
videos,
the purge largely functions as an
extended metaphor for the way entire
groups of people become disposable in
our current economic environment.
In this case,
the new founding fathers literally
specify one day out of the year the the
rich can eradicate the superfluous poor
who are deemed economic burdens as the
Revolutionary Dante Bishop says,
it's a lot easier to just kill the poor
than to provide them with health care,
welfare,
housing,
et Cetera.
We also see how the purge can promote
the interests of the well to do in
society.
We're actively profit off all the chaos
and the first film,
the upper middle class San and family
makes bank selling home security systems
to everyone in their gated community in
the purge TV show.
All of this is still front and center.
The rich and well connected are throwing
parties from secured houses while
everyone else is forced to fend for
themselves,
especially in the inner cities.
But one of the things that's really
interesting about the TV series is that
it explores how order emerges in an ard.
Now,
if that sounds confusing,
just stick with me.
Consider how the purge is basically the
temporary suspension of society.
It's laws and norms and institutions all
go out the window once the clock strikes
seven.
But in the TV show we see how even in
anarchy,
different kinds of social bonds will
arise amidst the anarchic murder.
Thon one of those seedlings of order is
a market,
a means for people to exchange goods and
services.
This one just exists for only 12 hours.
Now the purchase always been lucrative,
don't get me wrong,
but so far we've mostly seen profit that
happens before or after the purge,
like home security systems,
guns,
insurance.
You get the idea in the show,
we see how people coordinate actions by
skipping the brute force and using good
old fashioned cash.
For example,
we learned many cab drivers work on
perch night to take advantage of the
surge pricing and how we're going all
night.
You passing guys do,
he's driving around crazy.
But I've heard surge money elsewhere and
assassin takes contracts to kill people,
but only during the hours in which it's
legal is conspiracy to commit murder
still a crime if the murder happens on
the purge.
And do you declare that on a 10 99 well,
I digress with all the poor people the
purchase got rid of.
There's also a lot more capital just
sitting in the pockets of the new
founding fathers.
Big Wigs that us,
we follow a couple going to an nff,
a purge party for the sole purpose of
stomaching,
the brutal in difference of the elites
in order to Schmooze and NFFA party
member to invest in their new projects.
And no doubt we'll probably see a fair
amount of insider trading happening at
these 1% or purge parties.
So money is one way to organize things
instead of beating people to get what
you want.
Markets can facilitate exchange,
but there's one other way that TV show
explores order amidst the anarchy.
Social contracts at its core,
the idea of a social contract does that
we sacrifice certain rights to enjoy
living in a society.
So even if I want to steal candy from
the children as a hobby,
I have to give up this past time to
enjoy it.
Not living in the purge for 365 days a
year.
The purge films of largely emphasize the
way humanity acts when the law is
suspended,
when the social contract ceases,
when the clock strikes seven and without
threat of legal retribution,
people revert to their primal selves as
they release the beast.
It's a specific narrative of human
nature proposed by philosopher Thomas
Hobbs to theorize that before
governments came along,
life was basically the Beta version of
the curve,
but it's a narrative to purge.
Franchise has been challenging.
We've been in the first purge or the
government needed to sow discord to get
people hyped about murder nine.
While the show certainly has strong
elements of a hobby and war of all
against all,
it's not quite so simple,
rather than everyone reverting to their
allegedly natural and violet selves
without the threat of below man,
we see that most people just want to get
along.
Many employed the purge altogether and
even within the purge we see a kind of
social contract starting to emerge.
For instance,
paramedics are left alone not because of
some law,
but rather as a social norm.
Safe with us were off limits.
I'm renting person.
Others signed literal contracts that
forfeit their rights to purge as they
attend parties or pull all nighters in
lockdown office buildings.
Once the Burj begins,
his 38th floor will be locked out as a
safety security on all workers including
the both of you have signed waivers
giving up their rights to purge on this
floor for the entire evening.
However,
we see a bar that suspends all purging
privileges based only out of mutual
respect.
Slash sphere for the owner of the bar
somewhat like hops is Leviathan,
but unwritten laws in the form of social
norms aren't always so rosy.
The show looks at the darker side as a
woman having worked her ass off for
years is teased with the opportunity to
make partner at her prestigious firm,
but the unspoken rule that to her
progress is her unwillingness to
reciprocate her bosses.
Creepy propositions,
although he hasn't come out and set it,
she knows the only thing standing
between her and her dream is her
unwillingness to put out.
We're only two episodes in the seeing is
beholds 10 episode series focuses on
purge tonight.
We can definitely expect to see more
commentaries on human nature in the face
of chaos.
So thanks again to the purge on USA
network for sponsoring this video.
Also,
I'm going to leave you guys for the list
of things I would do during a purge
import exotic pets.
Cut The tag off my mattress.
Arrange large purchases with no sales
tax.
File my taxes.
Roger gently get like $1,000
worth of fireworks.
No pick up my dog's poop from the
sidewalk.
A ton of copyright infringement.
File patents for things I didn't invent.
Reverse engineer or popular game and
sell it for cheaper.
And definitely,
definitely double parking.
So be sure to watch the purge Tuesdays
on USA network and as always,
peace guys.